[Music]
are you a Big Brother fan I'm still
curious how the opportunity to be on
Celebrity Big Brother came I you know I
am NOT a super fan like everybody seems
to be in the regular versions but I got
caught up in last season I saw a girl
named Jessica and the promos I go she's
kind of a beautiful human being so I
ended up getting caught up in the season
loss here and the cast was so great with
Paul and Cody and Josh and Christmas and
I just got caught up in this world and
towards the end of the season
Julie Chen said we're doing a celebrity
version I go oh that's great you know I
can't wait to watch that my agent called
about three weeks later and said would
you be interested by any chance I know
it's a long shot and doing Celebrity Big
Brother I go it's funny you asked and
Here I am talking to you can you talk
about all those other players you
watched in the past what is your
strategy gonna be going into vows what
are you gonna do what are you not gonna
do I think what's interesting about this
year's Celebrity Big Brother in regards
to strategy it's a truncated expedited
version of the game it's a three-week
version there's ten contestants it's
already knives out will be no floaters
let me know hanging against the wall 20%
of the house will be nominated if the
traditional gameplay is in play the
first week of eviction so if you think
you're gonna make friends and do a cabin
and play the wall go hey man how you're
doing you all right that ain't happened
and friendships aren't coming out
because the knives will be immediately
out so I'll be very weary of that and
worried about these young bucks that do
this for a living
you know I forgot that you know
sometimes to get the cast I go who's the
old guy who would see there's always a
young guy an old guy a good-looking guy
I'm the old guy the cast blew my mind
I'm the old guy I still think I'm Justin
Bieber and good-looking so I figure that
up
what are you most nervous about so
you're gonna be in this house for
hopefully two and a half weeks and the
cameras are gonna be following you
around 24/7 so what are you most nervous
about I'm really nervous about crying
because I am missing my kids already I
got 7 year old twins and a beautiful
wife and I miss them already
I remember going into the sequester a
part of the bit I'm like I can't believe
I'm doing this
why what am i doing you know so I'm just
gonna miss them dearly so if you see me
sobbing in a corner and the fetal
position crying just know that I'm
missing my children but you know there's
so many things I'm worried about I don't
know where to begin
you know I'm worried
getting really comfortable - a little
too comfortable on camera I'm talking
about being a parent are you worried is
there any added pressure to making sure
you're not embarrassing your kids or
doing stuff that you might not want your
kids to see cuz you know the cameras are
on 24/7 they are on 24/7 being a
so-called celebrity you know they the
cameras a man I mean for a long time and
I've done a lot of stupid things and
they're well documented so daddy's gonna
have to sit them down sooner or later
and go out kids I guess I'm gonna tell
you so this will be just maybe if I do
something stupid on the big brother
it'll just be another another another
footage for the pile I need to show them
when they're when they get a little
older and you don't have any cell phone
no technology no communication to the
outside world so you've already kind of
had a little bit of that with being in
sequester so how hard is that gonna be
for you no communication of the outside
world is very difficult obviously the
family component is is going to be the
hardest but I run a business through my
phone I don't have an office I don't
have you know I don't have a secretary I
run a business through my phone I never
noticed how much I run said business
through phone until phone was gone from
me you know I was leading my hotel room
to that my words my thought big brother
stole it from me so I yeah that that's
gonna be very difficult
yeah as I said I run a business through
their or name communicates so it's gonna
be very typical but you know it's be
hard for everybody here and how
competitive are you willing to get are
you gonna backstab blind side turn
celebrities against each other you know
I'm very competitive I do have a set of
ethics though that I will adhere to I'm
a friendly guy but if I start getting a
railroader or backdoored I'm not afraid
to bring the knives out you know but I
want to leave here playing a clean game
I do and that's what I'm gonna do if I
become honestly friends I have a
connection with someone
I will not evict them and talking about
ethics a lot of people go into the house
you know say something stupid do
something stupid think they're the most
loved and come out and they're most
hated how careful do you have to because
you are in the public eye already that's
really a good question I'd even think
about that so I just brought it up to me
you know I was just gonna affect my
business so what you're saying wow
that's interesting well I hope I don't
do you think stupid but don't count on
that um you know I'm gonna be very weary
of that obviously and you know being a
person of interest let's
it's a hard word celebrity it sounds
weird but it could affect your business
outside it here thanks for bringing that
up and just scaring the living
you-know-what out of me so but I will
protect that because I spent years of
growing the business of Sugar Ray and
I'm proud of it and I don't want the
songs the people love to be affected by
the way I play this game now you know
this game comes with slop and all that
stuff are you going all-in are you ready
to eat that slop have you have you been
preparing
I am so bummed out on the slop component
of this thing I can't even tell you
preparing I hate oatmeal I hate it with
a passion when I go to restaurants i
order off the kids menu to day still so
I have a real finicky persnickety eating
habit and boy that slop is gonna be a
killer if you see me I'm just gonna be
like so bummed if that slob comes my way
I'm probably setting myself up for a lot
of slop this way but it'll make it fun
and interesting but you'll see a lot of
complaining that'll bring out the tiger
in me and not in a good one and before
you want to before you've been
sequestered there were a few photos
released out of the Big Brother house
did you get a chance to see them what
did you think of the house so far I did
see them and you know it looks like the
Big Brother house you know they they it
doesn't stray too far the the motif
change little and no they're kind of
doing a Hollywood thing you know the
show busy type thing so I feel right at
home no next to my Oscar and my not
Grammy and my not Emmy but yeah no it's
cool I just got a call that I they're
doing it'll be fun but it's still the
Big Brother house it is what it is you
can dress it up however you want is the
Big Brother house with all the drama and
backstabbing and friendships you like
but there were a few perks released you
all get your own bed there's an expresso
machine they have a square table what do
you think of all these perks like were
you hoping that it would just be the
rough game or you'd have to share beds
are you secretly happy about that well
listen we are celebrities and we need to
be treated like who we think we are so
of course is gonna be coffee I better my
own room
they're my my own bed but I could sleep
with Gary Busey though I I did I just
come out of my what that did right yeah
the whole bed is good that's great
that's fantastic and you were previously
on Celebrity Apprentice
so what do you think is gonna be harder
Celebrity Apprentice or Big Brother
absolutely without a doubt the more
difficult of the two shows between
Celebrity Apprentice and Big Brother
is Big Brother you know Celebrity
Apprentice though very taxing and
everyday you got to make the impossible
happen and that was draining is a very
exhausting show and you have to ask
people for money which I'm really hard
time doing least enough to do that in
the Big Brother house but living in
there away from your families it is very
difficult Celebrity Apprentice you went
home at night to a hotel in New York a
beautiful hotel and you know you got you
got to be in your own role for a while
you're never in your own world and Big
Brother that is the rub now it's what
makes it so much more difficult and a
lot of people use these reality shows to
help better their career afterwards so
what are you hoping to gain out of this
post Big Brother you know it's it's fun
and a lot of people are skeptical about
celebrities being on Big Brother and
maybe the money doesn't go to charity I
understand all that but I'm playing for
the market wrap charity man unique sugar
you know county fairs there's not enough
county fairs out there for sugar a to
support these twins I'm feeding but it's
fun look it's anytime you have the
opportunity beyond such an incredible
show as Big Brother that you're a fan of
on incredible network like CBS how you
take the chance you take the shot and if
it's but else you're taking it I shot at
it being not good for you you know not
everybody could not smelling like a
roses you know we're playing a game
we're competing so there's there you're
taking a chance you know like you just
told you you told me how does it feel to
affect your brand if you don't do well
in there you do something stupid I go I
didn't think of that because I'm stupid
so it's already affecting my brand you
see how this works so you don't know you
don't know who's in the house yet who
was someone you'd love to see in the
house well someone ironically I'd love
to see in the house would be a Gary
Busey type someone to come in and just
blow up the house immediately so guess
what
spotlights immediately opt me and I can
play the wall a little bit the first
week some of that gigantic personality
everybody's collectively goes I cannot
live with this whatever this is I cannot
live with this that scares me but what
scares me the most are these young kids
that do it for a living
okay they play competition shows for a
living so this is like oh this is fun
this is great I don't mind talking
nobody I don't mind standing up here for
an hour I get mustard and ketchup thrown
on me and so what I do
that scares me other 23 and Bob and got
like a 12-pack down here you know I
think I have one AB left that I haven't
seen her in about five years
so those are people you would least like
to see in the house they're the people
at least like to see but they're also
the people that I will certainly use my
Irish charm and dummy up to a little bit
if you know what I'm saying and so that
you know though there'll be many
alliances I think they won't they can't
they can't possibly last long so my if I
see some of these young bucks coming in
they're hot these alpha males
I will align myself I know how way to
sort of go ahead when I was younger I
was right there with you kids
congratulations on that win high five
you know hopefully I'll save me for a
while but you only get like one shot at
that you know just start singing Sugar
Ray and they'll feel nostalgic and keep
you around the whole time start singing
Sugar Ray and I think that'll be the
time I get booted out of the house you
know get out here Smash Mouth what are
you doing here lastly why do you think
you have what it takes to win the first
Celebrity Big Brother why do I think it
huh why do I think how about it takes to
win the first slubby Big Brother because
I got that Irish charm
I've got divine intervention on my side
and watch out for the old guy now the
old guy seems like a little slow but the
turtle
Obie's wins the race you know what I'm
saying with the age comes a little bit
of wisdom and I found a little bit of
wisdom
[Music]